In elementary school,
most of us learn
the human body is
75% water and we
are supposed to drink
eight glasses of water
every single day.
But that H2O knowledge,
that's evaporated.
Hey, hydraters.
Trace here for D News.
Babies are wet.
Yeah, they are soaked in water.
A recent NPR blog post talked
about how hydrated babies are.
They are 75% water
when they're new.
Just for comparison,
potatoes are about 80% water
and bananas, they're 74% water.
As we grow older, we dry out.
Adult men are only 60% water
while women are 55% water.
The reason being
men tend to have
higher amounts of muscle
and women more fat, which
means muscle stores
more water and fat cells
are bit drier on average.
But the fluid is actually
stored all over our body.
Some is extracellular, stored
in the liver, the kidneys,
stomach, bladder, spinal
fluids, and so on.
But more than half is
actually inside of your cells.
The bottom line is that
water is vital to our health.
It helps lubricate joints.
It gives our waste
something to dissolve into.
It keeps our tissues
healthy and pliable.
But we lose it.
We lose it all day, every day,
sweating, pooping, peeing.
Constantly, it's
evaporating from our pores.
And if we don't replace
it, we become dehydrated,
and our body suffers
in a number of ways.
Which brings us to
a very good question
that D News fan Vijanti Persad
asked on our Facebook page.
What is the right
or required amount
of water intake for a person?
That is an excellent question.
We've all heard
that you're supposed
to drink eight glasses
of water a day.
But where did that come from?
No one knows.
The debunking
masters at snopes.com
couldn't even find
original research on it.
They talked to Barbara
Rolls, a nutrition researcher
at Penn State who's
written a book about water,
and even she doesn't
know where it came from.
The Mayo Clinic says the
science is contested,
but it sure is easy to
remember, so why not?
Honestly, a lot of our fluid
intake comes from food.
The rules say that we
need to drink fluid,
so if we eat a
banana or an orange,
we consume their fluid, which
is to say, we take their water.
Like fricking Dune, man, the
spice must flow and all that.
An orange contains approximately
eight ounces of fluid.
But if you drink a lot
of diuretics, like soda,
your kidneys start to shed
sodium, meaning you need more
to replace it, which is bad.
So while, yes, by drinking
sodas you're drinking fluids,
you're doing it wrong.
Exactly how much
water or fluid you're
supposed to drink
every day depends
on things like body size and
how much exercise you get,
how hot and dry the climate
is and whether you're
sick or pregnant.
The truth is it
probably wouldn't
hurt you to drink 8 to 12 8
ounce glasses of fluid per day,
but a really good way
to test whether you're
drinking enough water is to
look at your pee-- seriously.
When I was hiking in
the desert, the guides
told us that it should
be clear and copious.
If it's yellow, that
means you're dehydrated.
So drink up and keep a BPA
free water bottle around
to fill it up directly
from your tap.
What do you do to stay hydrated?
Give us some strategies.
Let us know in the
comments, and thanks a lot
for watching D News everybody.